this is weird but true scandal has
rocked the world of award-winning nature
photography you wouldn't think there'd
be a scandal in the world of nature
photography true story there is a
Brazilian photographer named Mario
Cabral took this stunning photo of an
anteater approaching a glowing termite
mound at night this is a photo that he
took isn't that gorgeous you see that
anteater moving in well guess what the
photo has been hanging in a British
Museum because people Revere it and so
they just discovered Cabral had used a
stuffed anteater to take the photo yes
and this is a huge scandal in the world
of photography now they're trying to
question the authenticity of other
famous photos Cabral's have taken
there's this photo of a wild mustang
standing proudly in the wilderness
people are worried about it there's this
photo of a Timberwolf swimming across a
swollen stream look at that wolf go
there's this dramatic photo of a shark
attacking a boat something didn't seem
right there's this flock of flamingos
walking in the snow
and finally this photo of a group of
aggressive Galapagos Tortoises fighting
over some food people are worried about
[Applause]
you